[Musique]
je quitte la vie politique on devoir
immédiat pour l'instant et bien c'est de
répondre aux besoins de cette petite
fille dont j'ai été beaucoup privé ces
dernières années mais en fait il ya
alors excusez-moi je suis pas tous en
tête
[Musique]
gardez donc votre mépris crétins et vos
leçons de république pour votre propre
parti
[Musique]
ne vous en déplaise je me permets cette
impudeur parce qu'elle est de notoriété
publique
[Musique]
vous avez devant vous un accident qui se
vit bien et qui préfèrent aujourd'hui
être devant vous à vous dire ma vérité
plutôt que d'avoir été avortée en fait
on cacher la poussière sous le tapis
ça veut dire qu'on va mettre ça dans les
campagnes françaises sondées ce sont des
femmes oui enfin oui bien sûr ça y est
nous allons
[Musique]
il est temps pour moi d'avoir une
expérience autre que la politique j'en
ai besoin j'en ai envie
[Musique]